welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to whilst avengers endgame feels
like the final chapter in the MCU we of
course know that there are more movies
to come down the line this includes a
standalone solo black widow movie which
may have some people scratching their
heads throughout this video I'll be
breaking down whether the big decision
that she makes in the film can be
reversed and if so how it could happen
there will of course be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything about the movie then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for click in this video I hope you
enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown over whether that big moment
can be reversed okay so in Avengers
endgame Hawkeye and black widows out to
gain the soul stone in order to help
reverse the snap that saw the death of
half of all living things in the
universe similar to Thanos in infinity
war they arrive on Varro Mir to discover
that in order to retrieve the soul stone
one of them must lose something they
love in the end it is Natasha
aka Widow who does this and this
sulfurous soul exchange allows Hawkeye
to retrieve the stone and therefore
complete his goal it's a heartbreaking
moment and one that definitely feels the
most surprising out of the whole film
but is there a way that this can be
reversed well Hulk upon carrying out the
snap even admits that he tried to bring
her back though apparently this failed
but did it really remember Natasha's
body is unborn Mia in 2014 therefore if
she was resurrected she would wake up
here and not back on earth like hope
resumed this could lead to her being
trapped on Verona and potentially having
to formulate an escape plan with Red
Skull who will likely be set free from
his confines as a guide to the stone now
that it's been secured down the line
this could lead to him becoming the main
villain for Black Widow as I'm sure many
will agree that he was slightly
underutilized in the overall Captain
America or in the solo movie I could see
the two having to work together to
travel back to earth but then skull
betraying her once they arrive and
becoming the big foe for the final part
of the film
and that's theory one out the way of how
to reverse it ii could come when steve
sets out to return the soulstone Devorah
mir in his final mission before the end
of the film
we know that Steve returns the soul
stone for sure and perhaps this soul for
a soul trade works both ways with Black
Widow being granted her life once more
now that the object is back where it
belongs I could definitely see this
being revealed down the line as it's
clear in the final scenes of Avengers
endgame that Steve has more to say we
just cut to his past with Peggy Carter
he could go on to inform Sam and Hulk
that she's out there and still alive of
course the big elephant in the room that
we keep coming back to is that Black
Widow has a solo film in the MCU and
whilst I've seen many say that this is a
prequel it doesn't really fit into the
way that more will tend to do things
well I do think will happen is that the
film will jump between two different
time frames the majority of it will
predominantly be set in Budapest and
will show Widow and Hawkeye meeting for
the first time and then the latter part
will show her fate after avengers
endgame if this isn't the case I think
at least in the post-credits scene that
we will see Widow and Boromir waking up
alive and well the biggest criticism
that there is around Avengers endgame is
that Natasha and Bruce never really
properly got to have a relationship with
each other which is disappointing for
fans who are so invested in the
characters let's be honest everyone
wants to see her back and marvel
obviously see money in the character
otherwise they wouldn't be making a solo
film how great would it be for fans that
feel like they've lost her and to
finally get her back and this no doubt
would be reflected in the MCU and of
course love to hear your thoughts on
this theory and whether you'd like to
see the character return or if you think
her arc is over with comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my breakdown of what the
earthquake line in endgame meant which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care
peace
[Music]